♪♪
♪ I wiggle around
on this chair ♪
♪ I guess I look adorable ♪
♪ Not trying
I swear ♪
♪ And you better get home soon ♪
♪ 'Cause when you're gone
all I do is think about you ♪
♪ 'Cause you're so
irresistible ♪
♪ Sexy and cute ♪
♪ Don't make this girl
wait long ♪
♪ I don't think
I'm that strong ♪
♪ With me is where you belong ♪
♪ I want to feel you now
so I put on your shirt ♪
♪ It smells just like you ♪
♪ And I slip on your socks
and now I'm not blue ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm reminded of you ♪
♪ And I know
that it's true ♪
♪ That you think that I'm cute ♪
♪ When I do what I do ♪
♪ To feel closer
to you ♪
♪ I use your old toothbrush ♪
♪ The fact that it was in your
mouth gives me a huge rush ♪
♪ I put on your ball cap ♪
♪ And I sit on the couch
and I watch the game ♪
♪ Shove handfuls of creatine
down my throat ♪
♪ So we weigh the same ♪
♪ Your face is
all I see ♪
♪ I fit you perfectly ♪
♪ I think that I am forgetting
how to be me ♪
♪ But I don't care ♪
♪ I went to your job
and did a presentation ♪
♪ They told me to tell you that
we should take a long vacation ♪
♪ Then I found your hairs
in the sink ♪
♪ And I glued them to my face ♪
♪ Close my eyes and I run
my hands up and down ♪
♪ To feel closer to you ♪
♪ I put a pickle
in my underpants ♪
♪ To remember how excited
you get ♪
♪ When I do my sexy dance ♪
♪ Then I ♪
♪ Pee standing up ♪
♪ Down my leg
it runs ♪
♪ And I cut my hair short ♪
♪ But not
the pit ones ♪
♪ Then I go through the trash
and I eat your old food ♪
♪ So I poop what you poop ♪
♪ And I think what
you think ♪
♪ Do you like my new ink ♪
♪ Scream at 14-year-olds
on Xbox 'cause I... ♪
Lost!
♪ Push my feelings way down ♪
♪ Watch your porn and jack off ♪
♪ Then I light my farts
to feel closer to... ♪
Sup?
♪ You you you you
you you you you ♪
♪ I'm not here
because there is just you ♪♪
(chuckling)